el país que ASUME Luis Ignacio luradas
Silva Brasil eligió a su mandatario de
los próximos cuatro años en medio de la
polarización que dejan estas elecciones
el nuevo presidente tendrá que tomar
decisiones contundentes para combatir
temas como el hombre según datos
oficiales 33 millones de hogares pasan
hambre en el país sudamericano es decir
el 15% de su población Y aunque las
Naciones Unidas lo sacó del mapa del
hombre en 2014 la cifra ha retrocedido
durante las últimas dos décadas en
septiembre la tasa de desempleo en
Brasil disminuyó por séptimo mes
consecutivo hasta el nivel más bajo
desde 2015 sin embargo la agencia
Nacional de estadísticas informó que
alrededor de 9.5 millones de brasileños
se encuentra sin trabajo actualmente
Brasil todavía sufre las consecuencias
económicas de la pandemia Y aunque se
espera que el producto interno bruto
para 2022 sea del 2.7% siendo superior a
la de Estados Unidos este no representa
un crecimiento exponencial el medio
ambiente es uno de los temas cruciales
durante la administración de bolsonaroz
se le acusó de no proteger activistas
indígenas y de desarrollar políticas a
favor de las Industrias según el
Instituto Nacional de pesquisas
especiales más de 47.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de zonas verdes fueron
deforestadas durante dicha
administración en cuanto al liderazgo
geopolítico Brasil ocupó El séptimo
puesto de Las mayores economías del
mundo entre 2010 y 2014 en comparación a
los últimos años posicionándose en la
casilla número 12 de igual manera se
esperaba que el país sudamericano
asumiera al liderazgo del bloque
económico de los bricks sin embargo las
estrategias no han sido suficientes para
lograr su objetivo